mes chers collègues le ministre bonjour
la séance est reprise en accord avec le
gouvernement nous pourrions avancer les
séances de questions orales
initialement prévue le mardi 18 mai et
le mardi 8 juin respectivement au jeudi
6 mai et 3 juin
y at il des observations c'est pour
après monsieur iwata blessés voilà là
pour l'instant je suis sur des
informations plus générales
j'ai parlé des questions orales à
déplacer ce que vous avez une
observation par rapport aux questions
orales nom très bien donc nous actons
les jeudi 6 mai et 3 juin
il en est ainsi décidé une autre
information
donc vous avez encore le temps chers
collègues nous pourrions inscrire jeudi
6 mai après midi à la demande de
monsieur eric jean sanitas président et
de monsieur vincent de la et rapporteur
de la commission d' enquête sur les
concessions autoroutières un débat sous
la forme de questions réponses sur les
conclusions du rapport de la commission
denquête puis à la demande du groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
un débat sous la forme d'une discussion
générale sur le thème écriture inclusive
langue d'exclusion ou exclusion par la
longue
y at il des observations je n'en vois
pas il en est donc ainsi décidé une
autre information
par courrier en date du 6 avril le
groupe les républicains demandent que le
débat sur l'avenir institutionnel
politique et économique de la nouvelle
calédonie inscrit à sa demande à l'ordre
du jour du mardi 4 mai soit organisée
sous la forme d'une discussion générale
et non d'une série de questions réponses
décidée enfin dernière information
par courrier en date du même jour le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires demande de réduire à 45
minutes la durée de la discussion
générale sur les deux textes inscrits à
l'ordre du jour de son espace réservé du
jeudi 15 avril
y at il des observations non il en est
donc ainsi décidé encore une dernière
information est ensuite pourront
procéder aux rectifications de vote en
application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la constitution ainsi
que de la loi organique de la loi du 23
juillet 2010 prises pour son application
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
émis lors de sa réunion du 6 avril 2021
un avis favorable
13 voix pour aucune voix contre à la
reconduction de monsieur jean christophe
niel à la direction générale de
l'institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire
par ailleurs conformément aux mêmes
dispositions la commission des affaires
économiques a émis lors de sa réunion de
ce jour un avis défavorable 9 voix pour
20 voix contre à la nomination de
monsieur philippe baptiste à la
présidence du conseil d'administration
du centre national d'études spatiales
la parole est à présent monsieur dany
wattebled pour une mise au point au
sujet d'un vote aussi la présidente
c'est juste pour procéder pour le compte
du présent malhuret claude malhuret
agression de vote sur le scrutin public
du 6 avril dernier
répondant au numéro 101 sur le projet de
loi comportant le respect des principes
de la république
c'est à dire claude malhuret souhaiterez
s'abstenir sur le vote de l'amendement
merci la parole est à présent madame
françoise gatel pour une mise au point
également au sujet d'un vote
merci madame la présidente donc je
souhaite apporter une rectification de
vote concernant le scrutin numéro 102
de la séance du 6 avril 2021 et portant
sur l'amendement numéro 2 135 lors de ce
scrutin notre collègue bernard delcros
souhaitez voter contre je vous remercie
madame la présidente
si chers collègues acte est donnée de
ces mises au point elles seront publiées
au journal officiel et figureront dans
l'analyse politique des scrutins l'ordre
du jour appelle à présent l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion de la proposition de loi pour
une sécurité globale préservant les
libertés dans la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur marc philippe
daubresse rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
vous avez cinq minutes cher collègue
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mais ce prix de la commission des lois
messia collègues nous arriver en bon que
aujourd'hui au terme du long périple sur
la loi sécurité globale préservant les
libertés la commission mixte paritaire
réuni 29 mars à l'assemblée nationale
est parvenue à un accord qui préserve la
quasi intégralité des apports du sénat
dans le souci permanent de mieux
protéger nos chances d'europe tout en
respectant les libertés publiques sur
les polices municipales tout d'abord
prenons acte de la montée en puissance
des polices municipales l'article 1er de
la proposition de loi prévoit d'élargir
à titre expérimental les prérogatives
judiciaires des agents de police
municipale dans leur permettant de
constater davantage d'infractions sous
l'autorité du parquet
le principal point de désaccord entre
nous deux chambres porté sur la
possibilité pour les possibilités que
les policiers municipaux de procéder à
des saisies
nous avons trouvé une rédaction en cmp à
tenir en équilibre conservant le
principe des saisies en matière de vente
à la sauvette et de consommation de
stupéfiants mais clarifions leurs
conditions de conservation et de
destruction ce qui était la principale
raison de notre réserve
la proposition de loi comprend également
plusieurs armes
kl utiles sur la police municipale
notamment tous les apports du sénat sur
la mutualisation des polices municipales
et l'intervention de l'échelle
intercommunale ont été préservés la
création de brigades cynophiles ou
encore les prérogatives des gardes
champêtres que nous avons renforcé sur
l'ensemble de ces points nous sommes
parvenus à un accord
il s'agit d'avancées importantes pour
nos polices municipales nous avons
également pu préserver les modalités
d'évaluation qui était notamment
souhaité par notre collègue françoise
gatel s'agissant de l'article 6 supprimé
par le sénat
la cmp a adopté une proposition de
rédaction commune qui fait de ce
dispositif une simple possibilité à la
main de la commune mais qui limite le
remboursement aux frais de formation
c'est donc plus une obligation mais une
possibilité
décidée par le conseil municipal j'en
viens au titre relatif aux forces de
sécurité intérieure s'agissant de
l'article 24
la réduction du sénat était adopté sans
modification
je profite de cette occasion pour
indiquer que cette rédaction comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs notre président lors de
l'examen de la loi sur les valeurs de la
république ne fait plus de l'arctique 24
accapare ticulier de l'article 18 du
projet de loi comportant le respect des
principes de la république
d'abord en créant une infraction dont le
libellé montre qu'elle est sans lien
avec la diffusion de données
en effet la provocation à
l'identification que vise désormais la
tique 24 peut s'opérer sans diffusion de
données
les deux infractions ne vise donc plus
la même chose
soit il ya provocation à
l'identification pour les catégories de
personnes visées par le 24 soit il y as
diffusion de données identifiantes sans
provocation et c'est le 18
de l'autre loi qui s'applique nous avons
donc en fait purger le vice initial des
deux textes concurrents je vous
présenterai justin amendements
rédactionnels de précision pour bien
distinguer douaniers en opération et
forces de l'ordre en opération de
j'en viens maintenant à l'article 23 qui
constituait le principal point de
désaccord entre nos deux assemblées
nous considérions que dans sa rédaction
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
cet article poser des questions au
regard des principes d'égalité de
proportionnalité et d'individualisation
des peines nous avions donc choisi de
centrer le dispositif sur les
infractions les plus graves et d'élargir
le champ des victimes concernées la cmp
a conservé les principaux points en main
de cette rédaction tout en réduisant la
durée des crédits proposés dans un
instant luc harvey vous présentera les
peaux les termes de la loi qui le
concerne je profite des instants qui me
reste pour le remercier parce que nous
avons très bien travaillé ensemble
remercier nos homologues rapporteur de
l'assemblée nationale et madame la
ministre remercié le ministre darmana
qui a été longtemps à secondes et qui a
bien fait d'en appeler souvent à notre
sagesse voilà notre accord pourtant pas
sur le nom de cette loi puis si vous
l'adoptez s'intitule désormais loi
sécurité globale préservant les libertés
je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur loïc hervé
rapporteur pour le sénat la commission
mixte paritaire vous avez cinq minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président la commission des
lois
chers collègues en complément de
l'intervention de mon collègue
co-rapporteur marc philippe daubresse
que je remercie également pour le
travail que nous avons accompli ensemble
j'aborderai peu plus particulièrement
les volets du texte qui m'échoit à
savoir la sécurité privée la
vidéoprotection la captation d'imagés la
sécurité dans les transports
c'est d'ailleurs sur cette question de
la captation et de l'utilisation des
images que des divergences subsistaient
entre nous deux assemblées nous sommes
cependant parvenu à les surmonter grâce
un travail approfondi mené menées avec
les rapporteurs de l'assemblée nationale
madame tout rond et monsieur fau vernier
je les remercie également avant d'y
revenir j'aimerais d'abord évoqué en
quelques mots les dispositions relatives
à la sécurité privée le sénat partageait
pleinement la volonté des députés de
mieux encadrer ce secteur et ce qui a
favorisé l'élaboration d'un compromis
concernant la sous traitance c'est la
version adoptée par le sénat qui a été
retenu
même si certains nombres de la
commission mixte paritaire aurait
souhaité imposer des règles plus
contraignantes il nous a semblé
important que la restructuration du
secteur ne prive pas les entreprises
privées de sécurité de la souplesse dont
elles ont besoin pour répondre aux
demandes de leurs clients qui peuvent
être amenés à organiser ponctuellement
de grands événements notamment en 2020 2
3 et 2024
s'agissant de l'accès au métier la
sécurité privée le texte qui vous est
soumis chers collègues et proches de
celui adopté par le sénat
la durée de séjour exiger des
ressortissants étrangers pour obtenir un
agrément est cependant porter de trois à
cinq ans il s'agit d'un point auquel nos
collègues députés étaient très attachés
afin de garantir un contrôle effectif
des antécédents judiciaires
en ce qui concerne les pouvoirs nouveau
confiée au cnaps et le conseil national
des activités privées de sécurité
nous avions une interrogation sur
l'opportunité d'introduire une sanction
pécuniaire pour les salariés un
compromis a été trouvé autour d'un
montant plus adapté aux capacités
finances financière des personnes visées
qui comme vous le savez sont des
personnes qui sont assez mal payés enfin
le débat que nous avions souhaité ouvrir
l'opportunité d'appliquer aux agents de
sécurité incendie les règles applicables
aux agents privés de sécurité se
poursuivra via une demande de rapport
que le gouvernement devra remettre dans
un délai de 18 mois sur les sujets qui
touchent à la captation d'image le sénat
s'est appuyé sur l'avis rendu par la
cnil à la demande du président françois
noël buffet et les garanties introduites
ont été préservés concernant la
transmission des images de vidéo
protection à la police par exemple
depuis des halls d'immeuble où les gars
nous avons trouvé des compromis pour
concilier la lutte entre les incivilités
avec la nécessaire protection de la vie
privée concernant l'usagé des caméras
mobiles par les forces de l'ordre
c'est la version du sénat qui a été
retenu la consultation immédiate des
images en intervention sur un possible
pour certains motifs opérationnels
précis mais leur diffusion directe dans
les médias étaient écartés afin d'éviter
tout risque de bataille médiatique
concernant enfin le recours aux drones
nous avions souhaité le réserver aux
circonstances où ils sont réellement
utiles les infractions graves ou les
lieux difficiles d'accès ou dangereux la
cmp a maintenu tous les apports du sénat
notamment les i dans une autorisation
préalable l'élaboration d'une doctrine
d'emploi et l'interdiction du recours à
la reconnaissance faciale sur
proposition du gouvernement le sénat
vous vous en souvenez avait autorisé à
titre expérimental l'utilisation des
drones par les polices municipales nous
avions fait part alors de nos
interrogations nos collègues rapporteur
de l'assemblée nationale ont eux aussi
exprimé des réserves
nous avons finalement décidé d'encadrer
encore mieux cette expérimentation elle
sera soumise à une délibération du
conseil municipal à une autorisation du
préfet sa durée sera limité à six mois
renouvelable et son évaluation renforcée
pour finir je signale que la commission
mixte paritaire a trouvé un compromis
sur la simplification des modalités de
contrôle de l'alcoolémie au volant à
laquelle nous étions au départ assez
réticent craignant qu'elle n'entraîne
une limitation disproportionnée de la
liberté d'aller et de venir nous avons
toutefois demi l'utilité de cette mesure
sous réserve d'un encadrement renforcé
en conclusion je salue à mon tour le
travail constructif de mener avec nos
collègues d
buté qui a permis de dégager un
compromis ambitieux tenant compte des
préoccupations exprimées par nos deux
assemblées et nous avons tenu avec le
présent buffet avec marc philippe
daubresse un certain nombre de points
durs dans cette négociation est
évidemment c'est dans ces conditions là
que je vous invite à approuver ce ticks
ce texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire mais chaque collègue s'il en
est convaincu comme nous le sommes que
des avancées importantes en matière de
sécurité sont nécessaires
alors cet accord en commission mixte
paritaire est une bonne nouvelle c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour le parlement et
en particulier pour le sénat qui a pu
apporter à ce texte des ajouts robuste
juridiquement puiser dans l'expérience
et les remontées de terrain des
collectivités territoriales que nous
représentons est dans une vraie exigence
de préservation des libertés publiques
cela a été possible que parce que nous
l'avons voulue dès le départ et nous
avons mené cette négociation à son terme
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent madame marlène schiappa ministre
a en charge de la citoyenneté
madame la présidente monsieur le
président du fai messieurs les
rapporteurs devrait servait mais
d'amener sénatrice mais sur les
sénateurs je suis heureuse de prendre la
parole devant vous aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de la présentation des
conclusions de la cmp sur la proposition
de loi sécurité globale préservant les
libertés texte dont monsieur le
président du fai indiqué il ya quelques
mois à raison je crois qu'il s'agissait
du texte le plus important en terme de
sécurité depuis la loppsi 2 2011
ce texte il contient de très belles
avancées je ne reviendrai pas
aujourd'hui sur chacune des dispositions
les unes après les autres
j'aimerais cependant résumer en quelques
mots l'esprit de cette proposition de
loi que le ministre de l'intérieur a pu
débattre ici avec vous d'abord il me
semble que c'est un texte de confiance
de confiance dans nos mers et dans nos
polices municipales nous voulons faire
confiance aux élus de terrain nous
voulons leur donner la possibilité pour
ceux qui le souhaitent avec l'article
premier de faire expérimenter des
compétences nouvelles à leurs agents
dans le strict respect de leurs
compétences et de celle de l'état nous
avons pu entendre ici ou là dans les
débats que cet article marquerait une
forme de désengagement de l'état ou
qu'il aboutirait à confier des missions
régaliennes à des agents de police
municipale qui ne serait pas en capacité
de les exercer
je tiens à redire ici solennellement que
l'ambition du gouvernement qui rejoint
celle qui est défendu par les
rapporteurs à l'assemblée nationale
comme au sénat
c'est bien une ambition de
démultiplication territoriale de la
sécurité en aucun cas de régression
l'enjeu pour nous c'est bien de donner
des moyens nouveaux aux forces
municipales et de permettre à ceux qui
le veulent de pouvoir mieux répondre aux
troubles du quotidien j'ai été élu local
comme vous et je sais combien il peut
être frustrant de ne pas pouvoir agir
sur les nuisances de tous les jours qui
empoisonnent la vie des administrés ce
texte nous permet de dire aux élus qui
le souhaitent
allez-y partir du principe que nos
agents de police municipale ne saurais
pas faire témoigne à mon sens d'une
conception curieuse de cette troisième
force à l'heure où elle s'affirme plus
que jamais comme un partenaire essentiel
des forces de sécurité intérieure et
j'en profite pour rendre un hommage
à tous les policiers municipaux qui sont
engagés particulièrement dans cette
période difficile que nous traversons je
voudrais ici rassurer avec cette fois
nous ne créons pas une sécurité à double
vitesse entre les communes dotées d'une
police municipale et d'autre mais au
contraire en renforçant en valorisant
les polices municipales cette loi
renforce l'intérêt pour les communes de
s'en doter
nul besoin ici de rappeler l'article 4
qui ne permet rien de moins que de créer
à paris la plus importante police
municipale de france et pour pallier les
difficultés des communes à se doter
d'une police municipale l'article 5
renforce les possibilités de
mutualisation au niveau intercommunal
comme jamais cela n'avait été fait
auparavant
sivu steve holmes le pca fiscalité
propre contrat de mise à disposition par
ailleurs l'article 20 du ca va permettre
la mutualisation des dispositifs de
vidéoprotection dans le cadre d'un
centre de supervision urbain qui réunit
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
bref tout est fait pour doter les maires
de capacité à véritablement mettre en
oeuvre une sécurité du quotidien cette
confiance que j'évoquais elle se traduit
aussi dans l'article 20 qui ajoute les
agents de police municipale
au nombre des agents des forces de
l'ordre qui seront rendus destinataires
de ces images de vidéo protection
ce qui me semble fondamentale sont aussi
les articles 22 et 22 bis sur les drones
les caméras embarquées auquel les
policiers municipaux vont désormais
pouvoir avoir recours pour les
compétences bien sûr que le législateur
leur attribuer dans cette seule limite
nous en avons débattu sur la question
des libertés récemment et à chaque fois
en coordination avec les forces de
sécurité intérieures bien évidemment
confiance ensuite dans notre secteur
privé de sécurité cette grande rampante
cette grande réforme pardon que nous
venons de refonte sans précédent du
cadre de la sécurité privée
elle ne trahit aucune défiance de notre
part au contraire la vise à accompagner
ce secteur qui est en pleine expansion à
lui donner un cadre à lui donner les
moyens d'être pleinement reconnue comme
un partenaire de confiance
cette confiance est là bien sûr pour
contrepartie la responsabilisation des
acteurs de ce domaine
charge à eux désormais d'assurer cette
montée en compétences et cette montée en
moyens notamment en vue des grands
rendez-vous qui sont devant nous je
pense bien sûr à la coupe du monde de
rugby
2023 pour aux jeux olympiques de 2000
4 conscience aussi dans la force du lien
qui unit la police et les citoyens
cette conscience elle s'exprime dans la
mise en place grâce à l'article 27 terre
que nous appelons de nos voeux dans le
cadre du bureau de la sécurité d'une
réserve opérationnelle de la police
nationale alignée sur celle ô combien
efficace de la gendarmerie nationale
elle pourra répondre avec des missions
rénové à la demande très forte des
engagements des français et à la volonté
que nous avons avec le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin de valoriser
et de continuer à faire bénéficier la
police nationale de la compétence de
réservistes toujours plus nombreux aux
profils plus variés et aux engagements
plus divers elle permettra de maintenir
dans les cinq années après leur départ
la qualification d'officier de police
judiciaire pour les retraités qui ont
bénéficié de cette qualité pendant la
période de leur carrière
cette évolution qui a été portée par le
sénateur leroy que je salue constitue
une avancée forte et apprécié pour les
forces
c'est également un texte de protection
de nos forces justement les moyens vidéo
notamment les drones g insiste
démultiplie les capacités d'action des
forces en les exposant moins aux dangers
de la voie publique ou en leur
permettant de porter secours dans des
conditions d'exercice qui sont parfois
terriblement complexe et dangereuse le
sénat encadrer leur usage de nombreuses
garanties dont il nous appartiendra
désormais d'assurer la déclinaison la
plus opérationnel possible et bien
évidemment la plus respectueuse des
libertés
je constate par ailleurs avec
satisfaction que les parlementaires des
deux chambres partage pleinement la
volonté du gouvernement de protéger
spécifiquement les policiers et les
gendarmes
ainsi les articles 23 sur les crédits de
réduction des peines 23 ter sur
l'extension jedid embuscade 24 qui
prévoit désormais un délit de
provocation à l'identification mais
aussi l'extension à l'article 27 10 de
la protection fonctionnelle à l'audition
libre pour les membres des forces de
sécurité intérieure sont autant de
dispositions qui viennent témoigner de
l'attention particulière que porte la
république à ceux qui les protègent
c'est enfin un texte de fermeté de
fermeté vis-à-vis de ceux qui brisent
des vies par leurs comportements
irresponsables sur la route en
assouplissant les possibilités de
contrôle de l'alcool
emi ou de la consommation des
stupéfiants fermeté vis-à-vis ceux qui
ne respectent pas les règles dans les
transports puisque nous avons porté une
disposition qui permettra de renforcer
substantiellement les moyens d'action
pour les opérateurs du secteur pour
lutter contre la fraude tandis que les
possibilités en matière de recours
vidéos sont par ailleurs renforcées dans
la loi fermeté aussi pour mieux encadrer
les produits dangereux comme les
mortiers cela était débattu fermeté
parce que je crois qu'il ne faut pas
avoir peur de ce mot je sais qu'ici vous
êtes toutes et tous favorables à ce que
l'état de droit républicain soit
respectée au final je voudrais dire
qu'avec le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin nous souhaitons
véritablement salué la hauteur de vue
des débats il salué la très grande
qualité du travail de messieurs les
rapporteurs lors des auditions lors de
l'examen en commission des lois cuisant
séance si le gouvernement regrette que
les règles de l'article 45 et fait
obstacle à ce que d'autres dispositions
qui nous semblait très attendu des
forces puisque est inscrite dans cet
épais elle comme pour mieux lutter
contre les rodéos urbains et refus
d'obtempérer qui blesse un policier ou
gendarme chaque jour pour durcir le cada
requises d'acquisition des armes de
précurseur d'explosifs eh bien nous
n'allons pas bouder notre plaisir si
vous permettez cette expression et nous
pensons qu'il est l'heure et surtout à
saluer l'esprit de consensus qui a animé
les membres de la commission mixte
paritaire et qui permet aujourd'hui
ensemble de présenter un texte de
compromis et un texte qui je l'espère
sera adoptée c'est avec le même esprit
de consensus et de sagesse républicaine
que nous allons examiner et je l'espère
voté le texte qui vous est soumis et
auquel le gouvernement apportera comme
celle usages que les simples amendements
de coordination et d'applications en
outre mer je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à présent madame laurence harribey du
groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains
vous avez six minutes chars collègue
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président messieurs les
rapporteurs sans surprise notre groupe
votera contre 7 ce texte on peut
souscrire à l'idée d'une coordination
des forces de sécurité nationales
municipales et privées en vue de grands
événements comme la coupe du monde de
rugby où les les jeux olympiques mais
pour nous ce texte semble à contretemps
enchâssée entre le livre blanc de la
sécurité intérieure le beauvau de la
sécurité et la future loi d'orientation
débattre d'un nouveau cadre légal 10h
des drones et des caméras embarquées ou
de captation des images par les forces
de sécurité auraient à nos yeux mérite
et une expertise plus approfondie et un
débat public préalable au final la
proposition visant à l'origine la mise
en adéquation des polices municipales et
de sécurité privée à partir du concept
de continuum de sécurité se traduit par
un tac un texte avec des mesures
disparates qui affecte la lisibilité la
sécurité juridique des principales
dispositions quatre difficultés
concernant les polices municipales nous
nous opposons au champ trop étendue de
l'expérimentation qui pourraient
contrairement à ce que vous disiez
madame le ministre dénaturer les
caractéristiques propres de la police
municipale police avant taux de
proximité du quotidien les agents de
police municipale titre expérimental
vont être conduit à procéder à des actes
d' enquête est contradiction avec l'en
en contradiction avec les limites
constitutionnelles encadrant leurs
prérogatives
concernant les dispositions relatives au
secteur de la sécurité publique de
priver pardon nous regrettons
l'assouplissement des règles notamment
sur la sous traitance avec le risque d'
enjeu
des prestations à la baisse et de
précariser le personnel de ce secteur
outre les habilitations donné au
gouvernement visant l'organisation du
cnaps et la formation pour l'accès à la
profession
plusieurs dispositions posent des
difficultés de nature constitutionnelle
le rétablissement à 5 ans de la durée
nécessaire de détention d'un titre de
séjour pour qu'un ressortissant étranger
puisse exercer dans le secteur où le
fait de confier des missions de
surveillance sur la voie publique contre
les actes terroristes aux agents de
sécurité privés ou encore la suppression
de l'habilitation spécifique de
l'agrément pour réaliser des palpations
de sécurité
les dispositions relatives à la vidéo
protection et à la captation d'image
nous pose problème aussi puisque les
garanties introduite par le sénat les
rapporteurs l'on dit sont conservés mais
elles restent insuffisantes et n'aurait
jamais dû relever d'une proposition de
loi
nous restons opposés à la quasi totalité
des mesures inscrites dans le titre iii
manifestement contraire à la
constitution en particulier aux
principes de protection de la vie privée
nous récusons l'évolution de la doctrine
d'emploi des caméras piétons qui vont
devenir des accessoires du maintien de
l'ordre public alors qu'elle avait été
au départ plutôt pour objet de sécuriser
les agents d'apaiser les relations entre
la police et la population
nous ne comprenons pas leur
établissement par la cmp des mesures
élargissent et élargissant les
possibilités des ports d'image et de
vidéo surveillance notamment dans les
halls d'immeubles
de même la possibilité pour la ratp la
sncf d'avoir accès aux images de vidéo
protection quelque part note un
glissement d'une mission de surveillance
à une mission régalienne
d'une manière globale les dispositifs
relatifs à la création ex nihilo et
l'encadrement des régimes légaux
intéressant l' usage des drones et des
caméras embarquées soulève des
interrogations pour nous enfin quatrième
élément les dispositions relatives aux
forces de sécurité intérieure
nous interpelle la cmp s'est accordé sur
une règle une réécriture technique de
l'article 24 qui laisse entière la
menace contre la liberté de la presse et
renforce les sanctions contre les
diffuseurs d'image et son articulation
avec l'article 18 du projet de loi qu'on
est en train d'examiner sur les le
respect des principes de la république
entretient un doute sur l'application
effective
même difficulté avec l'article 23 qui
supprime les crédits de réduction de
peine est là et la fin des remises de
peine automatiques
enfin nous restons opposés à
l'autorisation du port d'armes pour les
policiers et gendarmes
hors service dans les établissements
recevant du public
en conclusion le texte issu de la
commission nous inquiète dans ce qu'il
contient et surtout ce qu'il ne contient
pas la réforme de l'igpn la remise à
plat du schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre ou encore l'interdiction de
l'usagé dès l bd ou l'absence des moyens
de lutter contre les contrôles
d'identité abusifs et discriminatoire ce
texte pour nous ne favorisera en rien le
rétablissement de la confiance des
citoyens dans les forces de sécurité
vous avez madame la ministre soulignait
le changement de titre pour une sécurité
globale préservant les libertés nous ne
considérons pas que ça préserve vraiment
les libertés que guyane au contraire il
est porteur de dérives et c'est la
raison pour laquelle non seulement nous
voterons contre ce texte
mais nous déposerons et nous saisirons
le conseil constitutionnel je vous
remercie tout en regrettant que les
apports que nous avons essayé d'apporter
un aux textes pendant la discussion
n'ait pas été retenue ça nous aurait
peut-être amené à un autre notre
conclusion je vous remercie
merci
leurs collègues la parole est à présent
monsieur stéphane ravier
vous avez trois minutes madame la
présidente madame le ministre mes chers
collègues la chronologie de la navette
parlementaire est bouleversée par le
télescopage des articles 24 de cette
proposition de loi sécurité globale et
18 du projet de loi comportant le
respect des principes de la république
que nous sommes en train d'examiner
depuis quelques jours ces deux articles
reprennent sensiblement les mêmes objets
visant à protéger les forces de l'ordre
des captations malveillantes et d'image
mais ils sont présentés simultanément
dans le véhicule législatif en examen on
se souvient aussi de la volonté du
gouvernement de créer une commission à
sa mesure pour une nouvelle écriture de
l'article 24
ce grand n'importe quoi alors que les
français attendent de la clarté met en
lumière le mépris de l'exécutif pour la
démocratie représentative
un texte de sécurité globale doit
garantir une sécurité démocratique avant
tout ce en quoi on bascule dans un
régime au pouvoir démesuré
le rôle de l'état est de garantir aux
citoyens et aux collectivités la liberté
et la sécurité
la réalité montre que la sécurité se
généralise tout autant que le recul de
nos libertés perdues la république en
marche se met à courir et se prend les
pieds dans les marchés nous avons ici la
preuve au mieux de la mauvaise
communication au pire du désaccord entre
le ministère de l'intérieur et le
ministère de la justice
chacun porte dans son coin pour que sa
mesure pardon dans son coin et les
français qui attendent une conjonction
des réponses policières et pénal en sont
les premières victimes
s'agit-il d'une lutte d'égos d'un combat
de coqs d'une divergence de n'être de
ligne ou d'une stratégie qui mettrait en
scène le duo du méchant et du gentil
pour satisfaire tout le monde qu'on
examine la loi dans ces conditions là
c'est déjà insupportable mais passe
encore le pire c'est que ce cafouillage
affiche emea à mal la crédibilité de
l'état alors qu'il a tant besoin de
retrouver sa légitimité son autorité et
dire que
du locataire de beauvau à celui de la
chancellerie ce sont les mêmes qui ne
manque jamais une occasion de faire la
leçon sur le prétendu manque de sérieux
et de cohérence des parlementaires avec
un dédain affiché pour les communes
à ce stade je préférerais pourtant donné
la boussole et manettes à nos communes
plutôt qu'aux gouvernements caresses
elle aussi attendre pendant que l'on
apporte des solutions ciblées aux
problèmes de sécurité locales ce grand
n'importe quoi qui devrait entraîner le
rejet des conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire
en attendant que le gouvernement accorde
ses violons des sénateurs représentants
des élus et de la réalité des
territoires et des terroirs était en
droit d'obtenir un peu plus de respect
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent monsieur dany wattebled pour le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires
vous avez quatre minutes chars collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur paulin commission des lois mes
chers collègues mais si le rapporteur
nous nous réjouissons que la commission
mixte paritaire soit parvenu à un accord
sur ce texte qui était très attendu
l'adoption d'un nouveau texte visant à
assurer inscrits globale tout en
préservant la liberté est
malheureusement nécessaire car depuis de
nombreuses années nous assistons à une
nette dégradation du climat sécuritaire
dans notre pays les actes de violence se
multiplient notamment quand on est
policier nos gendarmes les pompiers
il est donc indispensable de mieux les
protéger
le projet ces fonctionnaires qui
participent à une opération de police
contre tous ceux qui se permettent de
dévoiler leur identité grâce à la
sagesse du sénat
la nouvelle rédaction l'article 24 il
parvient après avoir été l'objet de
nombreuses controverses
cette nouvelle rédaction de l'article
clos les polémiques en remplissant tout
à la fois cet objectif de protection
sans pour autant porter atteinte à la
liberté de la presse
je tiens aussi à rappeler que les forces
de l'ordre ne sont pas les seuls
concernés
les élus sont aussi trop souvent visés
par ces violences inadmissibles
la vocation de nos forces de l'ordre et
de protéger les français
ça les pompiers et deux mètres et les
médecins de leur porter secours
et celle de les élus de leur servir
quels ce risque retournement du devoir
protéger ce qui nous protège
car au delà des victimes directes ces
attaques portent aussi atteinte à
l'ensemble de leur public et à la
cohésion de notre société
il est grand temps que cela cesse ces
dispositions s'accorde d'ailleurs avec
la promesse qu'avait fait qu'a fait le
premier ministre parce qu'il avait
assuré sur l'événement devant le
scénario est le pays qui n'y aura pas
qu'il n'y a pas et qu'il n'y aura pas de
zone de non droit sans contrôle
d'identité nos citoyens attendent
légitimement un renforcement de la
sécurité les discussions porté par ce
texte permettront de donner davantage de
moyens aux forces de l'ordre dans
l'accomplissement de leur mission
ainsi la vidéo surveillance et la vidéo
protection sera étendu afin de permettre
à cette technologie de déployer tous ses
effets comme toujours le sénat a prêté
une attention particulière à la
protection des libertés publiques non de
ces ajouts ont été conservés dans le
texte final assez des gares nous nous
félicitons que ce décret que le décret
qui détermine les modalités de vidéo
protection notre pays soit dorénavant
pris après avis de la cnil
cette nouvelle garantie renforcera
encore les protection des libertés de
nos concitoyens à côté du secteur public
le secteur privé constitue un important
pilier du continuum de sécurité
la provision de lauwe que nous et que
nous avons examinés renforce le contrôle
de la sous traitance
elle contribuera à améliorer la qualité
des prestations et la légitimité des
sociétés les exécute
ce texte prévoit également une
expérimentation vise et visant à confier
des prérogatives de police judiciaire à
certaines polices municipales même si
j'aurais souhaité que le seuil pour y
participer soit plus fortement diminué
il est heureux que l'on déjà diminué
passant de le vase agents à 15 agents
pour abaisser ce seuil mais je voudrais
redire ici avec force à quel point il
est essentiel de s'assurer que les
petites communes ne soient pas pénalisés
le législateur doit veiller à ce que la
sécurité soit uniforme sur l'ensemble du
territoire
cela implique de tenir compte du fait
que les petites communes n'ont pas les
moyens de payer les agents de police
municipale
en définitive c'est donc à l'état qu'il
revient en premier lieu d'assurer la
sécurité de concitoyens
les lionceaux tel concours à mieux
respecter les français
le groupe les indépendants votera donc
en faveur de son adoption
tout en rappelant que la question des
moyens financiers consacrés à nos forces
de l'ordre
fondamental pour parvenir à nos fins
merci chers collègues je passe la parole
à présent à madame esther benbassa du
groupe des écologistes
vous avez quatre minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues entre état d'urgence sanitaire
les sécurité globale est la succession
de tests liberticide et sécuritaire dans
notre pays depuis plus d'un an devient
maintenant alarmantes
nul doute sur le fait que 700 et fut
conclusive
sans surprise sur ce sujet le
gouvernement sa majorité la reine et la
droite sénatoriale sont à l'unisson
réunis en ordre de marche eau dans les
starting blocks de la course à l'extrême
ce texte appelle désormais proposition
de loi pour une sécurité groupe global
préservant les libertés comme ma
collègue madame marie b je me demande de
quelle liberté
s'agit-il il prône la surveillance de
masse de la légalisation et l'extension
de l'usagé des drones au plus grand
déploiement des caméras piétons sans
préciser pour ce dernier outil
l'importance quant au contrôle de
l'action de l'agent dans le cadre de ses
fonctions il aurait été bien sûr
judicieux d'inscrire dans la loi que
cette technologie a pour but principal
le renforcement de l'action de la
justice est l'aboutissement des plaintes
des victimes de violences commises fabre
certains agents ce texte s'attaque à la
liberté d'expression en limitant la
dénonciation des actes répréhensibles
des forces de l'ordre par son article 24
pourtant la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme le
souligner l'ingérence dans l'exercice du
droit à la liberté d'expression doit
répondre à un besoin social impérieux
or comme le relève la vie de la
défenseure des droits l'infraction
initialement prévus n'étaient pas
nécessaires à la protection des
policiers et gendarmes
malgré sa réécriture la critique faite à
cet article ne sent pas pour autant
obsolète
il porte également une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté d'informer
le nouveau délit de provocation à
l'identification une notion floue ouvre
la voie à des interprétations
divergentes et arbitrages pouvant nous
nuire au travail des journalistes
ce sont ces images diffusées dans la
presse qui ont permis de rendre publics
par exemple à faire benalla n'en
déplaise au gouvernement
cet ex bleed le droit de manifester
parce qu'il crée un climat anxiogène
autour des manifestations publiques
il légalise les drones mais là
silencieux quant au n b d et aux
grenades de désencerclement que nous
servons pourtant être la cause de
nombreuses blessures et mutilations
alors préservant la liberté dit ou
appellation assez antinomique si je puis
me permettre
enfin nous sommes ou la création d'une
police municipale à paris nous nous
associons à la vision que la mairie de
paris a de sa future police municipale
une police de proximité format aux
questions sociétales et à l'image de ce
qu'elle protège mais nous sommes contre
le dangereux là franchement copains se
tête de prérogatives et statut de la
police et gendarmerie nationales de la
police municipale et de la seule
sécurité privée force est de constater
que ce texte ne s'appuie sur aucune
vision réellement
novatrice et complète de la sécurité en
france il n'a hélas de global que le nom
pour ces raisons le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires vote raconte
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à un richard du groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
quatre minutes cher collègue madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il dit je crois
compte tenu de l'inspiration de cette
proposition de loi est de rassembler
comme de l'assemblée nationale
cet accord était prévisible en tout cas
on pouvait le souhaitez et il s'est
réalisé
je crois qu'il faut s'en réjouir et il
est tout à fait naturel de souligner la
part qui ont apporté nos deux
rapporteurs avec leur travail très
intense et très méthodique et aussi
notre notre président de la commission
des lois auxquelles je tiens à rendre
hommage
je voudrais simplement sans revenir sur
les principales dispositions autant
désolé pour moi même si ça revenir donc
sur les principales dispositions leur ai
simplement livré à deux observations
politique à propos de ce texte le
premier
la première observation c'est le chemin
parcouru dans le rapprochement dans la
meilleure coopération entre les
différentes forces de sécurité quand on
voit ce qu'était la perception y compris
au sol la police nationale et de la
gendarmerie des polices municipales il
ya encore 20 ou 25 ans et que
aujourd'hui notamment à partir du savoir
faire développé par les conventions de
coordination et l'acquisition de reflex
professionnel partagé entre police
gendarmerie et police municipale
beaucoup de progrès ont été faits et au
fond la reconnaissance de la capacité
des polices municipales aujourd'hui à
devenir contributeur à une sécurité plus
active
notamment relevant des infractions de
proximité je crois que c'est le résultat
d'une longue évolution dans laquelle
chacun a mis du sien mais en particulier
le calice les collectivités locales ont
veillé au à la montée de compétences et
de savoir faire de leurs polices
municipales voudrait aussi souligné
évoquant un vieux souvenir personnel
j'étais à la commission des lois à
l'assemblée
dans ce temps lointains le premier texte
sur le sécurité sur les sociétés de
sécurité privées que nous avons adoptée
en 82 83 et partait de loin et la
prévention dans la société française
contre ces sociétés et la très grande
méfiance qui les entouraient on
demandait à un certain effort à la
majorité de l'époque sache plan
témoigner pour adopter un système
d'encadrement de réglementation mais qui
a contribué dans la durée à faire
nettement progressé sur le plan
méthodologique ces sociétés et leurs
salariés
et aujourd'hui ils ont toute leur place
dans le code de la sécurité intérieure
mais évidemment avec un système de
contrôle et un système de deux de
protection de la sécurité à l'extérieur
qui je crois grand un service la seconde
observation générale que vous leur
apportez c'est le rôle de l'image et de
la transmission de l'image dans les
techniques de sécurité dans l'île dans
les outils de la sécurité au quotidien
mais aussi de soutien aux enquêtes
judiciaires et la place qu'elle a prises
ça aussi ça a été l'objet d'une très
grande méfiance
souvenons nous lorsque dans beaucoup de
communes nous avons
année après année adopté la délibération
permettant d'avoir une visibilité une un
système de vidéosurveillance dans la
dans l'espace public avec un contrôle
organisé nous partions avec un préjugé
et des critiques extérieures qui était
très intense
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une pratique
très généralisé et si je m'en tiens à
une analyse disons un peu symptomatiques
le nombre de cas dans lesquels
apparaissent des critiques apparaissent
des observations négatives sur
l'utilisation de ces outils de vidéo
protection comme on dit aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement rares et donc nous nous
avons encore dans beaucoup de communes
notre commission de déontologie qui se
réunit annuellement pour faire le point
mais les situations dans lesquelles il
critique oui ya conflit deviennent
absolument épisodique donc il me semble
que nous avons fait collectivement très
deux assemblées un bon travail et je
dirais que les collègues qui manifestent
encore une critique vont nous rendre un
service
en soumettant sept succès doit au
conseil constitutionnel de manière à
nous garantir la sécurité juridique de
l'ensemble des solutions retenues
la parole est à présent mais c'est
jean-yves groupe
vous avez quatre minutes chaque collègue
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous arrivons au
terme d'une proposition de loi
controversée pour laquelle le
bicamérisme a fait son oeuvre ce qui
doit être relevé
cette proposition de loi apporte mes
chers collègues des outils de régulation
bienvenus notamment dans des secteurs
très sensibles qui pourraient fortement
recruter prochainement comme la sécurité
privée ou en plein essor comme le
recours droit c'est une étape
nous aurions souhaité livrer aller plus
loin dans la régulation des sociétés
privées s'agissant du contrôle de la
sous traitance ou de la qualité des
formations proposées concernant les
caméras est reporté
le texte prévoit également grâce à
l'apport du sénat de fixer des cadres du
âge qu on devrait affirmer la
prohibition de techniques telles la
captation des sorgues reconnaissance
faciale 1
la connexion automatisé de tourner il
nous appartiendra de suivre très
régulièrement la pertinence de ces
dispositions et de les réadapter en
conséquence au regard des pratiques qui
voulut plus vite que le droit je compte
ici prendre rendez vous avec mes
collègues du sénat au moment du budget
pour qu'il permette à la cnil d'assurer
pleinement la montée en régime et la
diversification de ses missions il
appartient en effet à la puissance
publique de pouvoir organiser les
contrôles adéquat
je souhaite également réaffirmer ici
notre attachement viscéral à ce que le
cadre de travail de nos forces de
l'ordre et forces de sécurité prennent
appui sur nos libertés fondamentales
usage proportionné et dé limiter
strictement aux missions et autant de
ses missions respect des libertés
individuelles et de la presse
c'est notre fil rouge c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle une majorité de
notre groupe continue de s'opposer à la
détention possible d'armes par des
forces de l'ordre hors service au sein
des établissements recevant du public
j'en viens à une interrogation majeure
s'agissant des dispositions liées aux
expérimentations de mise en commun entre
les communes de policiers municipaux
quelques dispositions de notre groupe
ont été adoptés comme la nécessité d'un
débat au sein de chaque commune
expérimental et police intercommunale la
publication des frais de formation
engendrés par cette réforme ou
l'élargissement des pouvoirs de
verbalisation des gardes aux espaces
nature et de l'embraser dans l'ensemble
ces expérimentations appelle quelques
réflexions d'une part non la police
intercommunale nouvellement créés ne
saurait être une troisième force de
sécurité lynn nul ne comprendrait que
cette réforme soit un prétexte des
engagements de l'état
deuxième interrogation et non la moindre
nous craignons que ces dispositions
puissent ouvrir la voie d'une sécurité à
deux vitesses avait une super police
intercommunale d'un côté et de l'autre
et de l'iniquité hausse et même des
intercommunalités de sécurité
l'aménagement du territoire que nous
portons est celle d'une intervention
publique constante qui vient corriger
des déséquilibres inscrit la force
publique dans tous les territoires y
compris ruraux de fass france
périphérique et d'outre-mer
l'expérimentation est un outil
formidable mais ici elles touchent à la
sécurité des billets
et des personnels à durera 5 à ce départ
y est en cinq ans il sera très difficile
de revenir à l'arrière aussi nous
demandons une évaluation rigoureuse y
compris sur le plan local je vais
interroger en fait sur la complexité la
lisibilité pour le citoyen les
dispositifs prévus
je souhaite vivement que nous ne
pensions pas par des revendications de
concurrence territoriale plutôt que de
coopération des outils de technocratie
territoriales qui au total desservir
nôtres nos citoyens de grand pouvoir
implique effectivement de grandes
responsabilités
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à la présidente
eliane assassi du groupe crc eux dès
lors que nous aurons réglé les problèmes
d'embouteillages sans escale il vous
avez quatre minutes mama présidente
madame la présidente à un ami les chers
collègues la france berceau des droits
humains tels que promulguée en 1789
serait-elle en train de rejoindre le
camp des pays où la démocratie est
fragilisé par le pouvoir lui-même
c'est en ces termes que s'interroge des
intellectuels du monde entier
dans un appel envoyé à emmanuel macron
la semaine dernière pour qu'il renonce à
ce texte parmi lesquels des
personnalités comme angela davis noam
chomsky jean ziegler est pas moins de
trois prix nobel de la paix ne vous en
déplaise
avec eux nous inquiétons du recul de la
démocratie dans le monde et en france en
pleine pandémie à l'heure où des
populations souffrent d'un recul global
des droits humains et des libertés je
vous lis solennellement aujourd'hui en
posant un point final au débat
parlementaire autour de ce texte nous
actons arcus sans précédent sur nos
libertés publiques l'état affirme son
autorité et la remise en cause de
celle-ci ne serait ne sera que très peut
tolérer des mobilisations importantes
ont permis une réécriture du si
problématique articles and cat
mais quelle réécriture ne soyons pas
dupes
car si la question de l' usage
malveillant de l'image qui posait de
sérieuses difficultés dans la
démonstration de l'intentionnalité a été
résolu la formulation finale de
l'article visant une provocation à
l'identification qui a pour objectif
manifeste de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité physique physique ou
psychique des policiers ou des gendarmes
ne posent pas moins question comment
prouver ou non ce but manifeste quand
une image et diffusé pour dénoncer un
comportement de violence policière par
exemple en outre bien d'autres mesures
qui seront aujourd'hui définitivement
adopté mériterait que ce texte soit
purement et simplement retirée en cmp
les arbitrages sont révélés avec de tic
puisque la philosophie globale de ce
texte était partagée d'emblée par la
majorité gouvernementale à l'assemblée
nationale et par la majorité de droite
au sénat tous deux sont donc parvenus à
leur objectif d'instaurer un continuum
de sécurité allant des policiers
nationaux policiers municipaux en
passant par les actions pète et les
agents de sécurité privés quelques
contraintes sont instaurés pour encadrer
des entreprises de sécurité privées en
échange de quoi les agents de sécurité
privés se voient accorder de nouveaux
pouvoirs
ils pourront être autorisée par le
préfet a effectué des missions de
surveillance de la voie publique dans le
cadre de la lutte antiterroriste et ils
n'auront plus besoin d'habilitation pour
procéder à des palpations de sécurité
dans le cadre de certaines
manifestations comme en octroyer de tête
pouvoir à des entreprises qui par
définition n'ont qu'un but marchands de
nouveau pouvoir sont également
transférés aux polices locales sous la
tutelle des merles et qu'elle se
substitue de plus en plus à la police
nationale sans en avoir ni les moyens ni
les formations requises
nous l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises
lors de l'examen du texte à ce maillage
fin du territoire en matière d'agents de
sécurité ce couple une extension des
mesures et de l' usage des nouvelles
technologies
certes la commission des lois du sénat
s'est efforcé à encadrer des dispositifs
proposés notamment en matière d' usage
des brawn mais cela est largement
insuffisant nous entrons désormais dans
une nouvelle ère
en matière de surveillance des
populations ce que nous ne pouvions
soupçonné il y a quelques années encore
aujourd'hui il s'agit uniquement de
capter des images nous explique-t-on
mais qu'en sera-t-il demain si les gars
at les garanties sont aussi faibles et
éphémère que celles apportées à la loi
si 2010 est alors le pire est taquin à
craindre
et cela n'a rien d'alarmiste que de le
dire gageons que les sages du conseil
constitutionnel qui seront saisis vous
fassent eux entendre raison pour l'heure
mes chers collègues
prenons la mesure de ce qu'implique
notre vote aujourd'hui pour notre pays
pour la sauvegarde de nos libertés et
droits fondamentaux et oppose au goût à
ces conclusions
merci madame la présidente je peste la
parole à présent à notre collègue
stéphane le rudulier pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez six minutes chars collègues
la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président en commission des
lois
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi sur
laquelle nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui à susciter
rappelons le d'importants remous dans le
débat public et a donné lieu à de
nombreuses manifestations sur la voie
publique
en dépit même des contraintes
particulières tenant à la crise
sanitaire
aussi c'est avec un certain soulagement
que nous nous apprêtons a voté
aujourd'hui en faveur du texte de
compromis sur lesquels se sont accordés
députés et sénateurs
le 29 mars dernier mais que de chemin
parcouru
avant d'aboutir à cet accord
rappelons-nous dès le mois de décembre
2020 peu après l'adoption du texte en
première lecture par l'assemblée
nationale le sénat pris en la personne
de nos cheveux deux chaires rapporteur
avait fait part de sa ville
détermination à améliorer
l'article litigieux ce fameux article 24
notre groupe s'était en outre
vigoureusement opposé à la désignation
une commission nommée spécialement pour
la réécriture de cet article rappelons
que dans le cadre de la navette le sénat
était seul saisi de la proposition de
loi adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
c'était simplement le respect de nos
institutions et de notre loi
fondamentale
mais cette opposition fut féconde
puisque la version sénatoriale de
l'article 24 élaboré à l'initiative de
notre commission des lois a fait l'objet
d'un consensus entre les deux chambres
en commission mixte paritaire
d'importantes garanties ont été
apportées
l'ultime version a totalement abandonné
toute référence à la loi de 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse tout en maintenant
l'objectif initial par la création d'un
nouveau délit de provocation à
l'identification des policiers et ce
dans un but manifeste de porter atteinte
à leur intégrité physique ou psychique
délit qui sera inscrit dorénavant dans
notre code pénal
c'est une écriture plus sûr d'un point
de vue juridique cette nouvelle
rédaction ne porte pas atteinte à la
liberté de la presse et lève toute
ambiguïté sur une pseudo pénalisation
d'intention nous ne pouvons que nous en
féliciter
outre on le volet de cet article traite
controversée de nombreuses modifications
sénatoriales ont été conservés dans le
texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
alors sans revenir dans les détails de
la proposition de loin plusieurs points
méritent selon nous d'être souligné et
mise en exergue
ainsi contrairement au texte initial qui
rendait l'expérimentation éligibles aux
seules communes qui emploient au moins
vingt agents de police municipale le
sénat a ouvert cette possibilité aux
communes qui disposent d'au moins quinze
agents de plus dans un souci de
cohérence
le sénat a souhaité que cette
expérimentation soit prévu non pas pour
une durée de trois ans mais pour une
durée de cinq ans afin d'en calquer la
durée sur celle du mandat municipal en
cours pour en mesurer pleinement tant
l'intérêt que les effets notre volonté
de mieux partager ce lieu protégé ce qui
nous protège nous a conduit à renforcer
les peines encourues en cas de violences
commises en raison de leurs fonctions
sur les personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique
ces thèmes seront applicables en cas de
violences commises sur leurs proches
également par ailleurs face à la
multiplication des intrusions dans les
exploitations agricoles régulière
la visite est cambriolée ou dégradés le
sénat a élargi les prérogatives des
policiers municipaux et des gardes de
champêtre en les autorisant à constater
le délit d'intrusion illégale dans une
exploitation agricole
ainsi de nombreuses garanties ont été
également été apportées par le sénat au
niveau des technologies de vidéo
surveillance et de captation d'image
garantie particulièrement nécessaire au
regard des risques qu'elles présentent
en termes de libertés individuelles
comme de libertés publiques
alors si nous devions omettre un regret
c'est la disparition des dispositions
adoptées par le sénat sur proposition de
notre collègue dominique estrosi sassone
qu'ils entendaient clarifier les
pouvoirs des policiers municipaux en cas
de délit flagrant commis dans les
parties communes des immeubles à usage
d'habitation
elle aurait sans doute permis de
renforcer la jouissance paisible des
propriétaires et les locataires
mais malgré cela et pour conclure nous
nous réjouissons que les dispositifs
sous été voté par la majorité
sénatoriale en faveur de la sécurité et
pour lesquels nous avions pris soin qui
ne s'accompagne pas d'un désengagement
de l'état est largement retenu
l'attention de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale mes chers collègues je tiens à
remercier chaleureusement notre
président de la commission des loisirs
françois noël buffet nos deux excellents
rapporteur mark fields vrai c'est loïc
hervé qui malgré les zones de
turbulences rencontrées par ce texte non
succombé aucune erreur de navigation
et pour ceux qui auraient encore des
doutes sur le bien-fondé et l'utilité du
bicamérisme l'enrichissement par le
sénat de ce texte apporte une réponse
sans ambiguïté pour l'ensemble des
raisons exposées
le groupe l'est républicain votera en
faveur de la proposition de loi élaboré
par la commission mixte paritaire
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et enfin j'invite
par dont françoise gatel à prendre la
parole au nom du groupe union centriste
pour six minutes et non madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le président la commission des lois
mes chers collègues rapporteur mes chers
collègues grâce vraiment à la qualité du
travail des rapporteurs et du président
de la commission des lois du sénat je
lève le doute
le groupe centriste votre race texte
avec conviction le sénat s'était assigné
comme objectif de dépasser tout frénésie
et postures pour adapter la loi aux
évolutions de la délinquance et de la
violence mais aussi aux évolutions des
nouvelles technologies lesquels peuvent
aussi se transformer par l'image en
ménage pour ceux qui nous protègent les
transformant en cibles et parfois trop
souvent déjà en victime tragique et
chacun de nous pense ici aux forces de
police et de gendarmerie qui parce qu'il
nous protège et ont été victimes de
drames tragique cet objectif et je crois
atteint le travail de la commission
mixte paritaire a permis de conserver
les apports essentiels du sénat et de
préserver ce qui est cher notamment loïc
hervé à nous tous
l'équilibré entre liberté individuelle
et sécurité préservant ainsi ce socle du
contrat social qui fonde notre
démocratie contre cette violence qui
gangrène notre société nous répondrons
par une loi ciselés et sécuriser
juridiquement et même apaisé sur
l'article 24 qui avait soulevé tant
d'opprobre
l'article 24 et déjà en est cicatrisée
il ne touche plus à la loi de 1881 sur
la liberté de la presse mais créé à la
place un nouveau délit de provocation à
l'identification des policiers qui sont
a certainement trouvé sa place dans la
protection de nos forces de l'ordre au
cours des débats au sénat j'avais attiré
l'attention de monsieur le ministre
d'intérieur
sur une série de points ayant trait
mcrib daubresse a été très attentive à
la police municipale et beaucoup de
points était satisfait par la lecture au
sénat
l'action de la police municipale ne
saurait se substituer à celles de la
police nationale ou de la gendarmerie
car il faut le rappeler
l'état doit assurer la sécurité sur
l'ensemble du territoire
les polices municipales elle gère la
tranquillité du voisinage et en cela je
salue des initiatives très positive des
rapporteurs sur la mutualisation des
polices municipales
je ne peux ne pas dire un mot sur les
dispositions dit l usage des drones qui
aboutissent à un encadrement qui
devenait pressant de nécessité je
reprendrai les mots des rapporteurs loïc
hervé ce régime d'usagé des drones et
robuste et s'inscrit dans l'avenir est
une alerte que je me dois de vous
adresser madame la ministre sur
l'expérimentation de l'article premier
visant l'extension des compétences des
polices municipales
le principe de l'expérimentation est une
excellente chose répond à un besoin et
son évaluation que nous avons renforcé
au sénat a été maintenu dans ces grandes
dispositions par la cmp avec nos
collègues rémy pointereau et quand ils
ferraient particulièrement sensible à ce
sujet et les membres de la délégation
collectivités territoriales vous savez
madame la ministre vous aurons nous des
interlocuteurs très coopérative mais
exigent enfin ici même je sais que
maxime daubresse a été sensible
j'appelais à plus d'anticipation sur
l'atterrissage de l'expérimentation et
le sénat a adopté notre amendement
visant à s'engager à garantir le
principe de libre administration des
communes et donc à ne pas imposer de
manière verticale et autoritaire un
futur transfert
de compétences des prérogatives
judiciaires aux polices municipales
alors même que la création des polices
municipales relève du principe de libre
administration des collectivités je
réitère cette alerte madame la ministre
on nom du principe de libre
administration des collectivités
d'autant plus fort que chat échaudé
craint l'eau froide
et cette expérimentation doit sécuriser
après son évaluation exigeante un
principe d'élargissement de ses
compétences seules collectivités
volontaires
je veux pour conclure encore une fois
remercier profondément l'implication
minitieuse exigeante de nos deux
rapporteurs le hic avec marc ribes
daubresse ainsi que du président leur
écoute et la rigueur
jointe à celle il faut le dire de
monsieur ministre de l'intérieur ou de
vous quand vous étiez obama dame
ministres ont permis d'atteindre un
difficile équilibre dont le groupe union
centriste votera donc ce texte en
réaffirmant que la sécurité doit se
concevoir comme devant évoluer comme
évolue notre société et avec elle les
lois encadrant son application
elle doit protéger les libertés et
constitue tout autant un des piliers de
notre démocratie et j'espère que nous
aurons su par ce texte
en tout cas à la fois apporter des
solutions aux peurs qui se font jour
dans la population et renforcer la
protection de ceux qui nous protège je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues et la discussion
générale est donc close chers collègues
je me permets de vous rappeler quelques
règles
au stade de la procédure et en
application de l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement
aucun amendement des recevable sauf
accord du gouvernement le sénat étant
appelés à se prononcer avant l'assemblée
nationale il statue sur les amendements
au fur et à mesure puis par un seul vote
sur l'ensemble du texte et non pas
article par article vote par sur chaque
article
mais bien par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte à la fin de l'examen
des amendements
je passe donc à la présentation
amendement du gouvernement et de celui
de la commission présentée avec l'accord
du gouvernement
article 22 un amendement numéro 2 madame
la ministre si vous souhaitez le
présenter merci madame la présidente
c'est un amant coordination avis de la
commission peut à vos robes parfait je
fais donc voter sur l'amendement
y at il des votes pour rentrer il est
adopté
alors nous passons maintenant à
l'amendement numéro 7 sur l'article 24 a
présenté par la commission nationale un
amendement rédactionnelle madame la
ministre vous rappelle damien présidente
parfait avec deux avis favorables je
mets au voile amendement numéro 7 qui
votent pour contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
nous passons à l'amendement numéro 1
présentée par le gouvernement madame la
ministre
un moment rédactionnelle madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur au
travail durable très bien avec deux avis
favorables je mets au voile amendement
numéro 1 qui votent pour contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
nous passons à l'article 31 avec la
maman 5 rectifié bis qui n'est pas
rédactionnelle mais un peu plus
conséquent madame la ministre si vous
souhaitez le présenter madame la
présidente c'est un moment coordination
qui vise à l'adaptation des dispositions
dans les autres mers allemand tradition
parfait monsieur lauwers favorable donc
avec deux avis favorables je mets au
voilà maintenant cinq rectifié bisquit
et pour contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l'article 31 de terre avec
l'amendement 4 rectifier
du gouvernement madame la ministre c'est
un moment coordination madame la
présidente
parfait monsieur le rapporteur favorable
avec deux amendements favorables je mets
aux voix l'amendement 4 rectifier pour
qu'entre qui s'abstient il est adopté un
amendement après l'article 31 kg pièce
l'amendement numéro 3 présenté par le
gouvernement
toujours coordination damien présidence
merci madame la ministre
après donc avec deux avis favorables je
mets au voilà maintenant numéro 3 qui
est pour qu'entre abstentions il est
adopté l'amendement 6 rectifiée
présentée par le gouvernement après
l'article 31 15 pièce madame la ministre
un moment coordination de la même
présidente parfait avec deux avis
favorables je me voilà maintenant six
rectifier pour contre qui s'abstient il
est donc adopté
[Musique]